[Music]
last year the San Francisco startup all
birds released a shoe it calls the wool
runner this eco-friendly merino wool
sneaker has since exploded in popularity
especially in the Bay Area where it's
become something of a staple in the
Silicon Valley uniform and this week all
Birds is unveiling its second product
the wolf lounger all Birds gave us a
pair to test and true to the company's
core philosophy they are very
comfortable
they're also surprisingly durable they
do get soggy in the rain
but unlike a pair of canvas sneakers
they dry out in a matter of hours plus
the moisture wicking properties of
merino has kept them remarkably stank
free for more than 100 miles of sock
free walks through San Francisco all of
which is pretty impressive especially
for such a simple looking shoe there's
an RNA I think we've created a product
that looks like it could have been
designed in two minutes
of course it took a little longer than
that designing a laceless shoe out of
merino wool actually required thousands
of hours of sketching and hundreds of
prototypes and I think you could argue
that yes our products are kind of
austere but I think they're also an
exercise in maximalism you know that we
have reared with truly celebrating the
wool and letting that be be all that we
make a noise about the earliest markups
descended from martial arts livers the
kind of thing you might have seen Bruce
Lee wear but the shoe evolved quickly
from there with the designers obsessing
over every last detail we thought like
we were letting ourselves off the hook
by relying on this kind of gaudy
over-the-top gusset and we challenged
ourselves to do better this one didn't
offer us the kind of support that we
were looking for especially around the
back of a shoe so we make this you know
big jump towards a slipper form which
was a breakthrough a seemingly obvious
one in hindsight but then the challenge
was to make this thing not look like a
slipper
starting to really zoom in on the detail
we've got the the scenes all in the
appropriate places and we'd arrived at
the pure simple form but it feels like a
like a familiar object that's opened a
different occasion than their owner and
they're really like the final sort of
icing on the cake was to take this away
from grays and browns and from contrast
souls into this plopped color and that's
been a really important sort of final
little signature on a product that I
think has been incredibly painful to
create that's something that I think
we're really proud about